The Joe Rogan Experience and so he just
goes along with all the woke nonsense
because he doesn't want to fight that
wing of his party he can't afford to
have a battle on the left yeah so that's
my big issue with him I know you have
others well my my biggest issue is he
lies a lot and he's probably well
certainly not more than Trump
uh oh please come on well listen I think
they both lie I mean I don't like that
more than this guy because I want to
just if you want to talk about Trump we
can talk about Trump but if you just
talk about Biden I don't think comparing
him to Trump does anybody any good these
just look at the police because they're
running against each other yeah okay so
it's kind of necessary it could when if
you want to talk about in terms of an
election but you talk about the terms of
the guy who's in the office right now
like why don't I like him well one of
the things that I don't like has nothing
to do with any of his choices is that
he's mentally compromised I think
there's something wrong and I think it's
clear as if the other guy AI isn't well
okay he speaks much clearer he he might
be crazy
he's crazy and stupid say all those
things but it still doesn't take away
from the fact that but there's something
wrong with Biden like he makes up words
he stumbles through things it seems like
he doesn't know where he is half the
time he's very very old that's my
problem with him okay well again we're
living in a world where perfect is not
on the menu these are the choices we're
going to have this is going to be who's
running next time you're going to have a
yes a daughtering old man you definitely
think that Biden's gonna make it to the
2024 elections because I'm not convinced
well who knows yeah he might not and
some might not Trump
right oh both of them could die at any
minute yeah absolutely when you were
like 70 whatever years old 78 years old
one is 77 one is 80. yeah that's that's
the end of the line yeah yeah I mean
you're on E I mean right you might make
it to town but you might might die on
the side of the road there's also blue
zones where people live to a hundred
they don't look like those guys
no they look better yeah they're thin
and active and well Biden's thin that's
Trump is not but he's thin like skeletal
thin yeah like he's thin like frail like
where he looks like he's just gonna fall
down a lot I'll give you this point
Trump looks a lot and sounds a lot more
Hardy yeah and robust yeah and healthy
that's true he's a he's a city roach he
might eat the worst things he eats the
stronger he gets you can you cannot kill
him no I I he's also the only God that
did noticeably age the moment he got it
no we did we aged when he was in office
he was fine you're right he didn't look
like he aged he just still he always
looks the same but but he's a a criminal
and he's crazy and he's stupid and crazy
and stupid are two different things when
you say crazy what do you basically okay
let me let me give you an example stupid
is like uh Frederick Douglass is alive
or uh the stealth bomber is literally
invisible right
um or nobody knew Health Care was hard
to solve that's just stupid he's very
stupid crazy is like it's important that
uh
the crowd at my inauguration was the
biggest ever and I'm going to make an
issue of this for the first two weeks of
my presidency despite photographic
evidence of the contrary or I'm going to
steal these documents
that I don't even know what they are and
I don't care and I'm going to put them
next to the toilet at Mar-A-Lago and
then I'm going to fight you to take them
back or not conceding the election those
things are crazy or thinking I can
somehow charm Kim Jong-un in Korea
although that might be stupid sometimes
it crosses the line between both but
he's both stupid and crazy and he's a
criminal you know he's not he's not
being charged in these trials because
he's a liar they purposely didn't do
that apparently it's okay it's not
illegal to lie to the American people
and of course he did lie and continues
to lie he still hasn't conceded the
election which he plainly lost he's
charged with actual crimes
Criminal Intent to obscure
to I forget what the actual name of the
uh
law is but Criminal Intent to basically
steal the election or to coerce people
in the States from uh
I forget what it is and then there's
there's one uh forgery
um which is has to do with the elector
scheme uh Criminal Intent for what is
the forgery that's that's the Slate of
electors he was putting forward the fake
slate of electors
um and then there was
um
the one here it is we can read it three
counts of solicitation a violation of
Oath by public officer so he's trying to
get someone to violate their oath two
counts of conspiracy to commit forgery
in the first degree two counts of
conspiracy to commit false statements
and writing two counts of false
statements and writings violation of a
Georgia RICO Act conspiracy to commit
impersonating a public officer I wonder
what that is
uh conspiracy to commit filing false
documents and filing false documents
then this is all based on the election
results well there's also felony
solicitation of violation of oath felony
solicitation of violation of Oath by a
public officer that was what he when he
was talking to raptzenberger that's the
I need you to find me 11 000 votes uh
there's there's also one I mean this
there's two there's two cases about
trying to steal the election one the the
national case that uh Jack Smith is
Prosecuting and there's the one in
Georgia now they cross paths in a lot
but basically I mean yes he tried every
possible way to steal this election he
tried to do it through the courts he
tried to do it through State
legislatures he tried to do it through
intimidating Mike Pence he tried to do
it through the justice department they
talked about seizing voting machines
they talked about the using the Army I
mean you can't really believe that this
guy is not worse than Joe Biden I mean I
agree Biden is not a great president and
the hunter Biden stuff is a stinky
conspiracy not a conspiracy a stinky
Scandal that stinks to the high happens
if you think that that in any way
compares to what Trump tied to do you
just cannot tell unlike things apart and
you're you're saying this just based on
what happened after the election
just that stuff yes well that's that's
the Criminal part yes have you ever
tried a steel man his position like do
you think he really believes they stole
the election or do you think he's
[__] it gives a [__] it doesn't
matter who gives a [__] if he really
believes it but I mean if he really
believes there's evidence that the
election was rigged no I don't care no
first of all that was part of the
January 6 committee's findings he has
multiple people all the people around
him told him that he lost that election
including Bill Barr you know and he
admitted he's he had there's a one of
his quotes was uh that they have on
record of him saying I don't want people
to know I lost this election
that's kind of crazy well he's crazy
that's kind of crazy I mean it's it's
insane that you can't let go of the idea
that you can't be seen as a loser
there's a certain there's an he is there
is a I always said this in the beginning
it all comes back to that he is a
clinical case of malignant narcissism
it's not just a quirk it's actually in
the big book of crazy you know that
right I mean it's a real thing and it
affects everything he thinks and does
it's why foreign leaders were able to
Curry favor with him all they had to do
was kiss his ass and they got whatever
they wanted do I really think that he
wants to help Russia and Putin I think
Putin had him as soon as he said Trump
is a brilliant man
good you got me it doesn't take that
much he's a dangerous guy the idea that
that he could be president again as
opposed to Joe Biden again Joe Biden not
my first choice not my hundredth choice
but the other guy is a crazy stupid
Criminal